understood the corporation would
apologize to the match of the day
presenter or correspondent Ivor Bennett
is outside the broadcasting house with
the latest diver
yeah it's a very dramatic development
that's just broken in the last few
minutes Sky News understands as you say
that Gary lineker will return to
presenting GT's sport presenting duties
here at the BBC we understand that it
will be the BBC who will be apologizing
to Gary lineker after taking him off air
on Friday so quite the turn up here and
uh and this will be waiting for official
confirmation from the BBC nothing yet we
did expect a resolution to this issue
this morning at some point but I don't
think anyone really expected this we
were thinking there'll be some sort of
Middle Ground fudge and of neither side
having to apologize so that neither side
lost face but it seems not as I say Sky
News understands it'll be the BBC
apologizing to Gary lineker with him due
to return to presenting duties in fact I
can bring you the statement now from Tim
Davey the director general of the BBC
we've just had that confirmed now it's
quite a lengthy statement here it is he
says everyone recognizes this has been a
difficult period for staff contributors
presenters and most importantly our
audiences I apologize for this the
potential confusion caused by the gray
areas of the BBC's social media guidance
that was introduced in 2020 is
recognized I want to get matters
resolved and our sport content back on
air impartiality is important to the BBC
it is also important to the public the
BBC has a commitment to impartiality in
its Charter
and a commitment to freedom of
expression that is a difficult Balancing
Act to get right where people are
subject to different contracts and
on-air positions and with different
audience and social media profiles the
BBC's social media guidance is designed
to help manage these sometimes difficult
challenges and I'm aware there is a need
to ensure that the guidance is up to
this task it should be clear
proportionate and appropriate it goes on
accordingly we are announcing a review
led by an independent expert reporting
to the BBC on its existing social media
Guidance with a particular focus on how
it applies to Freelancers outside news
and current affairs the BBC and myself
are aware that Gary is in favor of such
a review shortly the BBC will announce
who will conduct that review whilst this
work is undertaken the BBC's current
social media guidance remains in place
and finally he says Gary is a valued
part of the BBC and I know how much the
BBC means to Gary and I look forward to
him presenting our coverage this coming
weekend so that's a statement
apologizing to Gary lineker from the
BBC's director General Tim Davey and
we've had reaction from Gary lineker as
well the presenter saying quite
succinctly I am glad that we have found
a way forward I support this review and
look forward to getting back on air so
and about turn from the BBC from just a
few days ago when they removed Gary
lineker from presenting teachings for
refusing to apologize for that tweet uh
criticizing the government's language
around the announcement of its small
boat policy tackling uh migrants
crossing the channel and arriving in the
UK they removed him from Air now he's
coming back in time for next weekend
with the BBC apologizing to its highest
paid presenter and an announcing a
review of its social media policy and
impartiality policy and guidance for
staff on using social media so quite a
dramatic development here at new
broadcasting house and once again
reaction from Gary lineker saying I'm
glad that we have found a way forward I
support this review
and look forward to getting back on air
thanks for that our Sports correspondent
Rob Harris is on the line now Rob
so Gary lineker will be returning to the
BBC as we revealed a short time ago and
confirmation from the corporation that
lineker will be able to return to
presenting this weekend with FA Cup
coverage he had been stood down on
Friday night in an unprecedented move by
the corporation which took odds with his
tweets and Gary lineker was determined
not to apologize for his tweets and his
determination to be able to continue
tweeting on political matters was at the
heart of this which did lead to the
discussions and the debates over the
application of the BBC's impartiality
guidelines and Gary lineker believed as
a freelancer he was able to be able to
post freely on matters politically and
he has just posted himself on Twitter
Gary lineker he said after a surreal few
days I'm delighted that we have
navigated a way through this I want to
thank you all for your for the
incredible support particularly my
colleagues at BBC sport for the
remarkable show of solidarity football
is a team game but they're hacking was
overwhelming what Gary lineker is
referring to there is the fact so many
of his BBC sport colleagues decided they
would not present they would not
commentate on matches which did lead to
match today airing on Saturday night
with pure Ambient sound from the
stadiums with no commentary no pundits
no presenter and reduced from an hour
and 20 minutes to just 20 minutes as I
understand it Gary lineker's team has
been in negotiations his agents with the
BBC all weekend and they were unwilling
to concede on his right to be able to
express opinions on matters that matter
to him particularly his support for
refugees which has been well known for
sort of several years he's had refugees
living with him and he wanted to be able
to have the right to continue to be able
to comment on political matters and uh
it has brought us ahead now with the
apology of form from the BBC and that
review of Just how Freelancers will be
able to post on social media
we have apparently had a tweet from Gary
lineker there it is after a surreal few
days I'm delighted that we've navigated
our way through this I want to thank you
all for the incredible support
particularly my colleagues where you've
actually just read this out Rob uh this
is just um Gary lineker saying what
you've just said
he says he's posting this in a Twitter
thread I have been presenting Sports on
the BBC for almost three decades and I'm
measurably proud to work with the best
and fairest broadcaster in the world I
cannot wait to get back in the motd
chair on Saturday we'll have to wait for
the next Post in what he says will be a
four tweet thread but certainly
Brad I think we've lost Rob Paris so we
will of course have comprehensive
coverage of this story throughout the
morning here on Sky News but meanwhile
back to our top story now and a crisis
in the UK's Tech sector was averted this
morning when HSBC UK bought the UK armor
of America's Silicon Valley Bank For a
symbolic one pound the deal announced by
the treasury in the Bank of England at
seven o'clock this morning means that
the deposits of the banks 3 300 UK
customers nearly all of them Tech
startups will remain safe and their
banking services will remain
uninterrupted the treasury in the bank
spent most of the weekend trying to line
up a buyer for svb UK which has some 6.7
billion pounds worth of deposits and
five and a half billion pounds worth of
loans well let's bring in our city
editor Mark Kleinman who broke the story
this morning Mark give me a flavor of
the kind of negotiations that have been
going on this weekend
yeah that's right and it's been pretty
evocative of the 2008 banking crisis to
be honest I mean where almost every
weekend doing that very febrile period
there were there was at least one bank
that was in negotiations with regulators
and the government about uh securing its
financial position in the case of
Silicon Valley Bank UK uh Ian clearly
this is not a household name it's not
big High Street lender like the banks we
were talking about in 2008 were the the
likes of uh Royal Bank of Scotland and
Lloyd's but at the same time this was an
important moment both in terms of
testing the bank of England's resolution
regime which was introduced after that
crisis of about 15 years ago but also
because of the importance of Silicon
Valley Bank UK to its customer base and
The Wider British technology industry
now clearly if customers had not been
able to access their bank accounts this
morning and were facing the loss of very
substantial deposits of part of an
insolvency process that would have
caused chaos not just in the technology
sector itself but in its supply chain
and Beyond and we saw over the weekend a
letter from hundreds of Technology
entrepreneurs to Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor warning about the impact of
Silicon Valley Bank UK's demise and I
think that that did Focus help Focus the
minds of those in the treasury over the
weekend you have to say in that the test
of the bank of England and the
government Bank resolution regime has
passed with flying colors in that this
deal was able to be executed and
delivered but before markets opened on
Monday morning and of course HSBC is
Europe's largest lender one of the
world's biggest banks is a safe haven
for Silicon Valley Bank UK we'll
obviously have to wait and see more
about what's happening in the U.S
banking industry with concerns about a
number of other Banks besides Silicon
Valley Bank but for the moment the
conclusion from those who have both
worked on this deal and those in the
tech industry over the weekend is that
is that it probably represents the best
possible outcome for this major lender
to Britain's technology sector
thanks Mark well joining me now for more
on this is James edsberg he's a banking
sector consultant James welcome to I
mean that's a very key point that Mark
has just made that the UK's resolution
scheme has passed this test with flying
colors hasn't it really
yes it has I mean under the steam 85 000
pounds worth per deposit to 175 000 per
joint account was was guaranteed but
there's a huge sigh of relief across the
tech sector this morning as the deal was
done uh over the weekend which is Mark
has just been saying guarantees really
the future it was an existential threat
to uh some of our kind of brightest
prospects in the in in the UK in terms
of technology and Life Sciences those
fast growth businesses that might well
be the big uh companies of tomorrow and
without their ability to be able to meet
payroll to pay for office premises all
the usual cash demands that there are on
startups and early stage businesses uh
they were looking uh really at a very
very serious situation and at a stroke
HSBC has really ridden to the rescue
James in the U.S the government said
over the weekend that they were
effectively backstopping svb in the
United States all depositors would get
access to their money why didn't the UK
government go down that approach why did
it seek to find a buyer instead for svb
UK
well I think you know the the the most
natural and the best thing for a bank uh
to be able to do when it gets into
trouble particularly one like svb UK
where it's a standalone Bank it had an
independent board of directors
um although as your correspondent was
saying a moment ago Silicon Valley Bank
sounds like it's just geographically
concentrated on the west coast of
California actually as a global bank it
does uh work and has clients and
customers in this uh Tech sector right
across the globe in China India Israel
Scandinavia Germany as well as in the UK
so I think it was the your first sort of
call if you're uh trying to solve this
situation is to find a buyer who can
swallow the whole business continue as
is and maintain the value of that asset
in other words the client-facing people
that svb has in the UK
um their approach it is a specialist
Bank focusing on on these VC bags and
early stage companies and if you can do
that and continue as as best you can
business as normal that's the best thing
uh that's the best thing for the bank
and its customers and the sector
James what's in this for HSBC
the access to a team and a uh an
approach which is focused on this uh
this part of of the economy
um svb was doing things that not other
not many other Banks were doing
um and if you talk to entrepreneurs they
will often say that when they go to the
High Street Banks they are met with
quite often a quite rigid and inflexible
approach to how uh um to to how they
kind of their needs are met uh startups
need flexibility they need facilities
they need to be talking to someone who
understands what the fundraising process
is and that skill set doesn't exist uh
hugely in many of the High Street Banks
so what HSBC is getting is quite a
narrow but quite a deep access to a
segment in the market which is not well
served and if they look after this asset
well then as I say that's good news not
only for the sector that may well be
valuable for HSBC as well that having
been said and your you know HSBC is a
huge bank it's Europe's largest bank
it's one of the world's largest bank and
if you look at the size of svb UK I
think they have about 5.5 billion in
loans compared to over a trillion
dollars in loans that HSBC has so svb
being UK being taken on by HSBC is not
in any way going to undermine or affect
HSBC strength
James what are the lessons here for
regulators and in particular I mean
svp's parent in the United States looked
pretty well capitalized it looked to
have done everything that Regulators
have have sought from Banks post the
financial crisis
I think there are a number of uh lessons
to be learned there the first thing is
the suddenness with which this happened
um you know a run on a bank now happens
at lightning speed we remember the you
know the days back in 2008 2009 when
people queued up at branches or at cash
points to take their money out to take
their money out these days it's the
question even in business banking as
well as in personal banking you open an
app you complete an online request to
transfer your funds and it takes minutes
to close an account so this really was I
think the pretty much the first run on a
bank of the digital age and that gives
you know cause for thought I think for
U.S Regulators the second thing I think
is really important to emphasize and
we're seeing this morning uh pressure on
what are called the U.S Regional Banks
or mid-tier Banks is that they are not
subject to the same stringent liquidity
um and other requirement that the the
world the the world's biggest banks the
US's biggest banks and European banks
are subject to and there is going to be
questions I think asked about whether
that stringent regime around liquidity
should be extended further down uh the
rankings of banks in the U.S so that
they too are subject to the the same
requirements uh and and and so far that
hasn't uh that hasn't happened but it
looks like other U.S banks are under
pressure this morning that may have been
suffering from the same issues that svb
was which was an investment in bonds
um uh which uh were under pressure as a
result of interest rates going up I
think the other reason why banking
stocks are under pressure today is that
this chapter what's happened over the
last three or four working days puts
into question this incredibly aggressive
increase in interest rates that the FED
has been pursuing over the last year
it's been the fast just increase in
interest rates uh in history and what
that's done is put under pressure any
bank that is holding a large proportion
of its Assets in bonds and as interest
rates go up those Bond values drop and
that's what left svb uh in trouble
okay James we have to leave it there
appreciate you joining me today thank
you
for joining me now it's Richard adey
he's chief executive and co-founder of
the British e-scooter manufacturer tour
its operations in the United States Bank
with svb and have their funds Frozen on
Friday Richard welcome to you
um how much money did you have on
deposit with svb in the US well earlier
the weekend when I was being interviewed
you kind of wanted to avoid it because
you didn't want to become the story but
we had 375 000. we kind of knew 250 was
protected so it was a relatively small
amount I mean we do reasonably good
treasury management
um but it would have been serious for us
I mean a relatively small business you
know you can't just take a hit of 125
000 but it was pretty clear something
was going to have to happen I mean when
we um when we went to the states we went
because uh we were we set up in the UK
and the UK promised that regulation
would change on scooters well it didn't
change we then got funded in the state
and we got funded by one of the VCS a
well-respected VC and you get encouraged
to go to svb yes and in fact in the UK I
have Investments where they actually is
part of the funding they had to do it so
they then you end up with 50 of you know
the sector effectively managed and if
they didn't do something on Monday
morning there was going to be really
serious one and you think that
Arrangement was pretty commonplace
throughout the United States if you're a
VC funded Tech business you were
basically pointed towards banking with
svb yeah I mean there was a very close
relationship between the venture capital
and private Equity sector and svb is not
like any other bank I mean I think we
have to be really careful here it's um
it was so close and some of and I don't
think this story has played out yet
we're all breathing a sigh of relief
because we want a simple story and the
simple story is it was poor treasury
management by sdb that's not the whole
story the story is there's much more
risky debt in there and you know we're
discussing wage how HSBC took on uh for
one pound but they'll have to look at
that loan book very carefully because
you know very soft loans were put in
um as part of what SVP was doing yeah I
mean it's by no means clear what happens
to the U.S arm of svb at all now I mean
all we know is that the US government's
standing behind the depositors right now
yeah I mean that's trick is it because
now they become the lender of Last
Resort and that changes the whole risk
profile of the banks that's not and
that's partly why the UK government
hasn't resolved this issue yet
um so for me I'd be the sigh of relief I
had a business in the UK that had eight
million
um held
um and in the US it was a smaller amount
but it is very tricky to know how this
this goes goes forward I mean the UK has
many problems it has problems with its
ability to raise funds in the tech
sector anyway and to have svb go into
Administration and to be honest HSBC we
bank with HSP in the UK they will not
provide the same service that svb
provided yeah very interesting though
here in the UK the majority of your
banking business was not with svb UK it
was with one of the traditional lenders
yeah what happened was when we started
so we started three years ago I'd been
in the states helping um Tesla out and I
came back and thought this a scooter
rental business is never going to work
you know there's too much money in it
but ownership of scooters would work and
I had a relationship with HSBC already
so that's how we started and we assume
that we would be building and selling
scooters in the UK because the UK
government said three four years ago
that was going to happen when it didn't
happen we went to the states we funded
out of the states we had a trucks which
is a really well respected micro
Mobility
um VC and they said look here we are
there's the money they didn't say you
have to go with um svb but it was almost
a badge of honor you know you I found
myself saying I'm of course in the
states we bank with svb so that's how
that happens so it happens partly just
by momentum but it also happens because
once you do a financing deal it wasn't
the case with us but with many others
you're forced to as part of the deal get
svb to do the banking so they must have
felt on Friday you know most of those
companies what can I do about this I'm
now cool I can't even do my payroll I
can't do anything and it's not even my
fault Richard it's been fascinating
talking to you this morning nice to meet
you some other business news stories for
you now and the life and pensions
company Phoenix group has reported a
full year operating profit of 1.245 5
billion pounds on an adjusted basis for
2022. that was up one percent on 2021
and was ahead of City expectations
for Phoenix which has 12 million
customers across the UK manages policies
previously sold by household names such
as Britannic Pearl Abbey life Scottish
Provident National provenance and
Scottish Mutual the company which also
sells new policies Under The Standard
Life Banner said it was expecting to
close its recently announced takeover of
some life of Canada UK in April and it
added that it continued to assess
further acquisition opportunities
the household and motor ensure a direct
line has plunged into the red as a
result of spiraling motor claims costs
and harsh winter weather the insurer
which recently parted company with its
chief executive Penny James made a
pre-tax loss of 45.1 million pounds for
2022 compared with the profit the
previous year of 446 million pounds well
John Greenwood who's the acting CEO said
motor claims inflation had been 14 of
where the company had expected it to be
during the year he added that 2022 had
seen the highest weather event costs for
more than a decade with 149 million
pounds worth of claims which was more
than twice as much as the 73 million
pounds that direct line had budgeted for
he said that the largest event was
December's freeze but 95 million pounds
worth of claims following prolonged
periods of Sub-Zero temperatures across
Scotland and Northwest England I can
tell you direct line Shares are
currently off by more than six percent
on the session so far
now there's real pressure on the
government to publish its semiconductor
strategy with warnings at the UK's chip
manufacturers will head to the US and
Asia without proper support but this
morning there's good news from a British
startup intrinsic semiconductor
technologist says it secured seven
million pounds worth of investment
joining me now is the chief executive
Mark Dickinson Mark welcome to you
before we get on to that there's an svb
angle here with you too because I gather
you were encouraged to bank with them
but you chose not to good morning Ian
yes absolutely
um I came under well pressure I mean uh
that there was uh those in the industry
see the sdb as a very important bank for
startups and and therefore
um some pressure to go and bank with
them
um in the end some are fortunately for
us we we decided to stay with a bank a
British bank that had been one of the
few banks that had taken us on board
during the middle of the uh pandemic
which was a really hard time to open an
account so basically that loyalty sort
of Trumps the the desire to go to a bank
which is lined up uh specifically for
for start but I I'm very grateful to the
government for having you know brokered
a deal which now means people like
myself can
sleep easy after a very tumultuous
weekend
I think lots of people now your
technology was uh your intellectual
property was developed at University
College London What specifically does it
do yes yes it's a we're a spin out of
UCL the technology is being worked on
for a long time 10 years or so at
University College London
um it's a Memory technology
um memory is an incredibly important
part of the semiconductor infrastructure
if you like all processes require memory
and we use it all the time it's a it's a
660 million billion dollar industry for
the type of memory that we are working
on
um and and basically our memory allows
in particular small and handheld
battery-powered devices to become much
more powerful than they are today and
and one of the reasons that's important
is because we want to add AI to
everything AI is is booming most of the
AI that we see today is done in the
cloud and this type of Technology will
allow that that type of functionality to
move to what we we call the edge to the
to those things that wearables for
example or sensors or things which are
at the edge of our Network they need
lots and lots of memory they need more
memory and we've got a very interesting
and new style of memory and what will
this funding enable you to do so we've
uh just introduced just um got seven
million pounds in funding um from a
range of VCS
um VCS that originally backed us and
octopus Ventures um a big UK VC of
course
um and that will allow us to to more
than double the size of our company
we're a small company so that's not huge
in numbers terms but it also allows us
to continue our development of this and
and take this this technology to uh to
commercialization to to production
status and to do that we need to partner
with
um with uh what we call research
facilities that allow us to manufacture
this in proper production lines and
that's very relevant for this to the to
the strategy if you like for
semiconductors that the government is
going to announce longer term what are
your Ambitions for the business I mean
obviously there's a big debate over the
likes of armed Holdings listing in the
US rather than the UK yes you're way way
off thinking about an IPO I presume
we're off yes some distance away from
thinking of an IPO but but that is for
us a very real if you like aspiration
and and one that we can hopefully
achieve within five years or so we have
a technology which is relevant to every
semiconductor device on the planet
practically and and therefore we've got
huge potential
um and replicating if you like the arm
model providing something which is an IP
which is licensed into a global economy
but not actually manufactured if you
like on the UK Shores designed on UK
Shores is exactly what what we want to
do all right Mark there's loads more I
wanted to ask you but I'm a favorite at
a time go see this thank you thank you
now life remains tough in the
hospitality sector just as they were
getting back on their feet after the
pandemic pubs bars and restaurants were
hit as a wave of rail strikes just
before Christmas wiped out lucrative
festive trade well today saw nightcap
the owner of the Cocktail Club the
adventure bar group and the Barrio
Familia group of bars and ants record
underlying earnings a 4.1 million pounds
for the six months to New Year's Day up
from Two and a half million pounds in
the same period a year earlier will
nightcaps chief executive Sarah
Willingham joins me now Sarah welcome to
you I mean new openings clearly are
proving very supportive for you yeah
we've actually we've we're really
pleased I'm a lot less pessimistic than
I was I think last time I spoke to you I
think that was uh sometime in November
and I was expecting this this half of
the Year actually to be pretty difficult
but I'm really pleased our customers
have held up people are still wanting to
go out the big thing for us more than
anything is the rail strikes that's the
one single thing that is impacting the
hospitality sector more than everything
else that we talk about the increase of
costs or uh the crunch on the consumer
it's it's down to the rail strikes
absolutely I think in this statement you
say the rail strikes cost you 1.2
million pounds During the period
presumably it's more since year end yeah
we have more to come as well that's that
that's the thing and I think the sort of
deliberate targeting of the really
critical days for Hospitality will
continue to see that the the High Street
will really struggle if they continue to
Target Saturday's Thursday this week
which means nobody goes out on a Friday
um and yet Hospitality as always you
know continues to just to do as well as
it possibly can to continues to Pivot
its business model continues to put on
more events on a Sunday or on a
Wednesday to try and compensate for it
people really really want to go out
there is the underlying demand is there
they just need to allow us to trade
Sarah what about this broader trend of
hybrid working I mean there's a lot of
concern about what it's doing for City
centers you don't appear to be on the
receiving end of too much of that so
what we've seen and it really is a
change in the way that people are
behaving actually without a shadow of a
doubt so Friday is much quieter than it
used to be Saturday is huge compared to
it's almost like an amalgamation of
Friday and Saturday Thursday is the new
big night out and we even see a Tuesday
weirdly I think that's the night that
everybody goes into the office so if
people are at home on a on a Monday and
a Friday we're seeing Tuesday is bigger
Thursday we put lots more events on that
tends to be a really good corporate
night Friday's really quiet in fact I've
Got Friends that own a gym and they tell
me that the Friday night is now the
biggest night in the gym you know I mean
it really is a shift in Trend but
Saturday is double what it used to be
Sarah what about inflation how are you
grappling with inflation do you think
it's peaked yet do you feel it's peaked
well I I think I mean the government
have been absolutely clear that that is
their biggest one of their biggest
targets for this week uh for this year
and if they can half the inflation they
can keep unemployment under control and
not increase the interest rates anymore
I think we will see the economy come
back into a stable by the end of the
year it's that along with the train
strikes is the most important thing that
we need to see we're very we will we
were lucky earlier later last year we
fixed most of our energy we've capped
our interest rates so and we've got
long-term fixed contracts with our
suppliers and of course we serve very
little food with with drinks it's a very
very simple business model so the
inflation has much smaller effect on our
business than you will see on a lot of
other businesses okay Sarah we have to
leave it there I'm afraid good to catch
up with you this morning thank you
thanks
now 18 years after closing its UK stores
the beauty retailer Sephora has returned
to the High Street for the opening of a
6 000 square foot store in Westfield in
West London Sephora closed its doors in
2005 after failing to compete with the
likes of boots and Superdrug but it
returned to the UK online only last
Autumn joining me now Sarah Boyd the
managing director of Sephora UK Sarah
welcome to you is this an acknowledgment
that it was a mistake to pull out of the
UK in the first place
well what I would say is the response
we've had this time has been really
overwhelming it's been it's been uh
incredibly moving and has far exceeded
our expectations speaking to people in
the queue some of whom arrived at
midnight the night before to wait for
the opening people had come from all
over the UK all all corners of the UK
and abroad different groups of people
people that come with friends it was a
fantastic energy so it was great to see
the excitement what made you choose that
location
we as you would expect are looking at a
number of locations both for now and the
future and we felt that Westfield which
is the biggest mall in Europe and had
this fantastic mix of mass market and
luxury FNB and also entertainment really
felt like home for us they're a
fantastic partner and we're really happy
with the space that we've got now
obviously your parent companies lvmh the
world's biggest luxury goods company
will you be selling any of their other
brands we do have many of their other
brands or all of the Beauty Brands are
represented uh in the store and also
online what's the typical customer that
you're targeting here can one talk about
it it's difficult to say because it's
very broad anyone and everyone is
welcome in our store and and online of
course and what we expect to do is to
create an environment where everybody
can have fun and be inspired and to be
unapologetically themselves so it's
really very very broad but we go from
quite young we've had school kids in
especially over the weekend there was
lots of school kids coming in all the
way up to the very elderly and really
from all backgrounds and profiles I mean
this is a ferociously compared
competitive market I mean quite aside
from boots and super drug you've got
people like Harrods launching their own
Standalone Beauty Brands now
that's correct but I would say and I
can't speak for the competition again
speaking to people in the Q and in store
over the last few days they're very
excited and very grateful for for us
bringing Sephora to the UK people know
us from when they go on holiday to the
US or France or Dubai and they've been
really excited by by us coming back so
it's been it's been very humbling now of
course you first put your toe back in
the UK Waters with an online business
called feel unique did that inform this
decision or was it going to be something
that happened anyway well this is
essentially our third step so quite
rightly as you say a little over a year
ago we bought feel unique and then we
launched Sephora online both with a web
and app version in October last year
which was also very very well received
so this is step three we're going to
learn an enormous amount from this store
we've learned a lot already in the first
four days but there's also a recognition
that we need to go further 75 of our
online orders are delivered outside of
London so we need to provide a physical
environment with more proximity to our
customers elsewhere in the UK and that's
what needs to happen next so the good
news is that if people are ordering
online right now 80 or over 80 of our
deliveries are made the next day so
people don't have to wait too long
you're clearly not worried about the
cost of living crisis
well what I would say is our single
biggest brand at the moment in store is
Sephora collection and Sephora
collection is a very very affordable
brand that is also exceptional quality
and so what we want to do with that and
also with our Minis and more which is
essentially our smaller size products
that we have traditionally near the
tills we want to make sure that we have
something for everybody at every price
point and what about this issue of
inflation do you think it's peaked
I'm not sure whether it's peaked but
what I would say is that we are working
very closely with our suppliers and also
with the other markets across Sephora
globally to make sure that pricing is
fair and competitive for our consumers
and that we do as I mentioned before
have things for every price point across
the board all right Sarah good Olivia
there good to see you this morning thank
you very much
[Music]
now the U.S dollar has come under
pressure this morning after the U.S
government's decision to step in and
restore investor confidence following
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank the
move is seen as potentially obliging the
U.S federal reserve to pause its current
rate hiking policy she can see Sterling
is up by a quarter of one percent on the
morning against the U.S dollar it was up
by more than half of one percent earlier
on today more or less unchanged right
now against the Euro The single currency
meanwhile also benefiting from Dollar
weaknesses up a quarter of one percent
right now against the dollar
well on the equity markets there was
mixed trading overnight in the
asia-pacific region as you can see uh
Tokyo and uh Sydney both finished low I
think Mumbai which isn't on the screen
was also in negative territory on the
plus side there were gains in both Hong
Kong and in Shanghai well in Europe
stock markets are deeply in the red this
morning all of the main continents
European indices quite sharply lower
look at that the Ibex in Madrid and the
mirbin Milan off by more than three
percent a piece the ducks in Germany in
the Kakarot in France both off by two
and three quarter percent there are some
gainers this morning talking points
include Deutsche Post which is up some
two percent in Frankfurt after striking
a wages deal with the unions well here
in London the ftse 100 is also in
negative territory off some two percent
right now in a broad base sell-off the
leading Fallout is the asset manager m g
which is off three and three quarter
percent that's on broker comments
Following last week's results all of the
banks are most of the asset managers are
off as uncertainty continues to hang in
the air among the leading fallers in the
foot seat this morning include Standard
Chartered Lloyds and NatWest group
outside the footsie there you go for
NatWest started chartered off five and a
half percent now Lloyd's off four and uh
a half percent nearly there as well
outside the footsie a lot of uh issue is
uh statements issued by companies
insisting they had no exposure to
Silicon Valley Bank or did not expect to
be affected by a possible failure of
that group all of them though are in
negative territory they include thg the
hot group hits off by a one and a half
percent moon pig which is off four and a
half percent and Naked Wines which is
two percent lower right now as for the
oil price well despite the weaker dollar
that has also been underwater this
morning about a Brent crude will
currently set you back
81.35 a barrel that is off one and three
quarter percent on the day will joining
me today it's Philip Shaw he's Chief
Economist at invest it feel good to see
you in person as well
um how much of a crisis has been averted
here by svb well we don't really know
and that's half problem and I think that
there's a lot of uncertainty about you
know what happens when a bank goes under
um during the global financial crisis it
was all about our banks safe and here we
think the banking system is is a lot
safer it's better capitalizes lots of
liquidity particularly with the larger
banks in the United States the smaller
Banks we don't know but one of the real
issues that that's come across is well
what happens to tech companies if
um the deposits have been guaranteed but
tech companies as we know are cash
hungry and if you've got svb no longer
lending to them and potentially the
smaller Banks thinking well we're not
sure of our own positions then you know
that tightens Financial conditions in
the tech sector and could have an
economy-wide impact yeah now all of this
has had an impact on the dollar as I
mentioned I mean the the FED has has
effectively backstopped fsvb in the U.S
why would that necessarily mean it has
to put its rate Rises on pause well it's
really the economic uncertainty the risk
is the that lending slows down or stops
particularly to one sector that has
contagion effects through throughout the
rest of the economy potentially and it
means that well that sort of tightening
is is doing the fed's job for it so the
FED must be thinking now well we've got
a mixed labor market report coming out
of the states on Friday with a strong
increase in employment but unemployment
going up participation going up but
we've also got the uncertainty caused by
the svb situation so now our best guess
is that the FED will probably raise
rates next week again by a quarter of a
percent
um but we're not sure and the the risk
is that the FED actually says well we're
sufficiently concerned about the
uncertainty not to do anything at least
this time yeah I mean the U.S economy
just keeps on churning out new jobs it
is quite remarkable isn't it yeah
absolutely and you know one of the
issues is that there's a very high level
of vacancies which is just under 11
million at the moment so it may well be
that the economy isn't moving
particularly quickly but you've got this
overhang of demand for labor which is is
being satisfied very slowly so the
economy carrier carries on creating jobs
yeah now of course we get the budget uh
here in the UK this week obviously the
treasury has spent all weekend looking
at svb UK by the sounds of it are there
going to be any Show Stoppers there
hasn't been much pitch rolling from the
treasury as we've had on previous
occasions well you know a cynical person
might say that you know we're more than
a year away from a general election so
this could be a little bit of a holding
pattern the public finances are getting
a little bit worse but by nowhere near
as much as the chancellor thought back
in November last year but even so that
there isn't much room to cut taxes at
this stage so you know our guess is that
you'll you'll see a couple of measures
you know a little bit of short-term
political gain perhaps keeping the
energy price guarantee at two and a half
thousand pounds rather than raising it
to 3 000. you know we all know about um
the fuel Duty increases not happening as
well one or two other things like that
really short short-term political gain
but really I think that the emphasis
will be on okay let's Shore up the
public finances maintain our credibility
that we've just re-one and do something
ahead of the possible election next year
I mean these are relatively stimulatory
moves though things like keeping the
fuel Duty freeze in place extending the
energy price guarantee how much of a
headache does all that create for the
bank of England well it complicates the
picture but obviously by nowhere near as
much as the so-called mini budget that
we had in September last year when when
the bank of England ended up raising
rates much more aggressively
um I think you know two's and Frozen
fiscal policy are pretty well standard
for monetary policy makers and they'd be
able to cope with them all right Phil
it's lovely to see in person again
thanks for joining me
well we're going back to the Gary
lineker story now uh the BBC director
General Tim Davey has been speaking
during the last few minutes about the
reinstatement of the presenter let's
have a listen to what he said we've
agreed and I've spent time talking to
Gary and we've had lots of discussion is
that between now and when the review
reports Gary will abide by the editorial
guidelines and that's where we are you
said this was your foundational
absolutely issue impartiality this was a
Line in the Sand
it just seems to have been a bit of
disruption to match the day and you just
abandon it if that was just a bit of
disruption to match today then you
probably weren't uh having the same
weekend I was having I think it was a
very big moment in terms of us saying we
have to take stock here we have to take
action we did take action which we
thought was proportionate
and as the BBC we believe we did the
right thing I think I did the right
thing
having said that I think you have to
look at the balance here and act fairly
and you know there's a lot of people
it's been unfair to Gary lineker then no
I think I've acted in the right way
through this it's always been difficult
as as everyone's been saying on this
affair there's been no easy answers it's
been tough to get the balance right but
asking Gary lineker to step aside I
think was
appropriate at that moment then we reset
and we do the things we've laid out in
this agreement which I think are right
and we go forward how are you so out of
touch
that was Tim Davey the BBC director
General speaking in the last few minutes
we'll have more on this story throughout
the morning here on Sky News
now in his budget this week the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt is promising to
step up investment in carbon capture
technology often seen as one of the most
effective ways of achieving Net Zero but
one of the main sources of CO2 in the UK
is the country's old and leaky housing
stock which means UK households consume
more energy than many of their
Continental European peers one potential
solution being touted for this is the
construction of Highly energy efficient
homes on production lines joining me now
is Jordan Rosenhaus he's founder and
chief executive of the modular house
Builder top Hatter Jordan welcome to you
I mean you're opening I think Europe's
biggest modular housing Factory what's
the um start for production well good
morning Ian it's a pleasure to be here I
know it's a very busy day starter
production is next year where it's going
to be 650 000 feet and it'll be
producing up to 5 000 units a year and
you're claiming yeah and it's a it's a
home an hour basically what's the
typical cost
typical costs should be no more than a
traditionally built house right now we
can compete with with all the
traditional house builders and over time
our cost basis should go down and as
we've seen the construction that's not
the case elsewhere how difficult is it
to get these houses onto the uh to
actually the locations where they're
going to be based given the UK's Road
network not difficult at all uh we we
haven't had an issue to date we think
that as long as you're within the
guidelines there shouldn't be an issue
at all right and how much construction
actually takes place on the site itself
and how much in the factory so we strive
to do over 95 percent in the factory so
there should be very little time on site
where you when there is construction on
site things generally go wrong so we do
as much as we can in a controlled
environment under these properties for
rent or for outright purchase we we look
to hit almost all tenure so we could be
for Bill to rent social housing private
sale
uh we we like to hit all aspects of the
market and how typically energy
efficient will these properties be
compared with the existing housing stock
in the UK
very very injury efficient so first
there's a lot less carbon in the build
in the actual build
um and then to operate the houses
because we can control the tightness of
the house with Precision Engineering in
the factory uh there's less leaky houses
so how are the houses warmed if you like
empowered right now we we use air source
heat pumps and um
all best practice standard stuff but I
think the key and the differentiator
between top hat and traditional is what
happens once you're heating the house so
it takes a lot less energy to heat one
of our homes versus a uh a traditional
house well this is presumably because
heat pumps come as standard that is much
more cheap I presume than retrofitting
an existing poem with a heat pump
absolutely because when you retrofit a
home with a heat pump you still have the
issue with the Leaky installation in the
Leaky house in general what about the
building materials how much CO2 are you
taking out of the process there so we
can build one top hat home for 127th the
carbon of a traditional brick and mortar
home wow how do you do that we use
timber frame we use different kind of
facades everywhere we can we strip back
on carbon so there's there's no use of
bricks then for example we don't use
bricks we use our own brick like system
that we've developed in-house oh so what
so what are they made of they're made of
a of a resin it looks just like brick
you can do any kind of design that you
like any kind of vernacular
they perform just as well even better
so that that that's a big way that we
can cut back on on carbon now
prefabricated housing in this country
has a bit of a patchy record but given
the quality of the prefabs that were put
up after the war how will you overcome
those perceptions
well in general Manufacturing in all
Industries has gotten a lot better so
with housing it's no different if you
use you know current manufacturer modern
practices you you could get a lot of
design variation and you can get a lot
more quality control definitely whether
you can get on site and much more so
than you could have in the 50s prefab
and I think people are starting to
recognize that okay well that's
mentioned we've got a budget coming up
this Wednesday what's top of your wish
list from the chancellor
think right now the the with all the
talk about energy I think that we need
to ask ourselves you know why aren't we
building homes that you know rather than
having to have an energy cap why not
have built homes that actually have an
energy Surplus so that they can feed
energy to the rest of the community and
I think we're right there being able to
do it currently and I think if with a
little Innovation and uh it's policy we
can get there all right Jordan good to
see you this morning thank you thank you
Ian
and a reminder that Sky News will be
bringing you full coverage of the
Chancellor's spring budget announcement
on Wednesday here on inking live of
course at 10 o'clock and then in a
special program from Westminster at 11
you don't want to miss that
still to come here on inking live the
science behind beauty technology don't
go away
[Music]
thank you
I'm Stuart Ramsey and on Sky's Chief
correspondent well there's a real sense
now that people are beginning to expect
that this whole airlift is coming to an
end and they're really really desperate
we saw snatch words going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a wall That's the
wall
we help you understand the world with us
for the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
Venezuela
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world they were convinced the
United States would become hooked they
were right
we're normal six version has just come
down I think it was a monster just
landed in between us
information on this could bring down the
entire network not just in Iraq and
Syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
it's so so hot
foreign
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now it's been more than 20
years since ghd launched its first hair
straighteners for supplying salons and
then the general public since then the
brand has become so successful that ghg
is now synonymous with hair
straighteners joining me now is the
chief executive of ghg Jerome Timmerman
Jerome welcome to you you've just got a
new product out which I gather has a lot
of science underpinning it oh yeah we
just launched it the first of February
and it has been nine years of
development so first of all it's now 20
years as you said that ghd is in the
tech beauty related to hair Focus so 185
degrees what we call is the perfect
styling temperature without with healthy
hair
now the next step for us is the hot air
Styler called Duet which also combines
airflow with heat that gives that first
in the world styler with no damage so we
are extremely proud of that so how many
physicists and Material Sciences do you
employ we are of more than 100 in
Cambridge talented people working day in
day out with the transformation of heat
and air and hair and after that of
course we also very fortunate to tap in
to the bigger Hub that Cambridge has
there's a lot of tech capability as you
know in Cambridge which helps us and
allows us to get this breakthrough
Innovation going so without getting too
technical on me it's it's all about
getting the optimum temperature at which
to to both dry air and style it at the
same time exactly that 185 degrees which
is very important and it's also the
software that that and the algorithms
that we have in our tools that can
change 250 times per second to get that
Optimum 185 degrees together with air
and that that's one of the tech that's
why I keep on calling it Beauty Tech
because there's a lot of complexity into
a hairstyler obviously the intellectual
property has been developed here in the
UK where is it actually being
manufactured this right now uh the
Traders are manufacturers in different
parts of the world so we are we are
manufacturing uh also in Asia but as you
said all the intellectual property is
here in the UK is in Cambridge where on
a day-to-day basis more than 100
Engineers are working on this perfect
and beautiful company and that's where
the economic value is really created
it's in the IP it's not in the
manufacturing oh completely completely
it's all about the technical engineering
and our investment in r d in Cambridge
we doubled our investments in the last
four years and we will double our
investment in the years to come right so
what are the next conundrums that you're
trying to crack as it were
well it is I I certainly think that
styling without a court is one of the
things that we that we want to do and I
think the more and more artificial
intelligence and the smart technology of
our plates will advance in the future so
the more we can create that as value for
the consumer the more we will do so
there's an element of Energy Efficiency
in in all of this as well it's trying to
decarbonize the process to an extent yes
sustainability is in in the core of our
existence so the example of the new duet
style it's it has 45 percent less energy
use than an average tool in the market
so this is when we develop our products
one of the key priorities we have moving
forward is our sustainability footprint
all right so there are more people going
to be hired by you in this country then
yes of course we will we will continue
to create products that create added
value for the UK but also for the global
Footprints we have we are now we are
more present in more than 30 countries
around the world already absolutely so
what are you seeing demand growing most
strongly right now
are we still seeing that's also
surprising we see demands very strong
growing still in Europe
but after that I think the U.S market
and the Chinese markets for us are very
strategical in terms of grow moving
forward we want a good hair day to
travel the world now you're part of
Weller Group which is owned by private
Equity what's the longer term scenario
is an IPO likely at some point well
that's all exciting stuff I think where
we focus on is growing the business of
GAC around the world but also to say we
as a company we look we work according
to public standards financial reporting
ESG footprint related stuff so we focus
on doing our business and uh that's what
we do today
all right Jerome we've got to leave it
there it's great to see you this morning
thank you thank you for having me
now we've got a bit of reaction to this
uh unfolding Saga involving Gary lineker
Lucy Powell who is Labor's Shadow
cultural secretary has just responded to
the BBC's announcement of an agreement
with the school sports presenter said
this is welcome and we will all be
pleased to see Gary lineker and football
coverage back on the BBC this weekend a
review of the BBC social media
guidelines is clearly needed but much
bigger questions remain about the
impartiality and Independence of the BBC
from government pressures well that's it
from me today there's much more than
Scotty's mobile app and on the website
with the reporting video content and
Analysis from our business team plenty
more on The Saga of Silicon Valley Bank
going up throughout the day